I'd like to now introduce our featured presenter Matt Rothe.
Matt is co-founder of the FEED Collaborative at Stanford University where he is
an educa- educator practitioner in
design thinking and sustainable food system innovation.
Matt is also a lecturer in
the Graduate School of Business Executive Education program where he frequently
engages with social entrepreneurs and executives
seeking to create social and environmental impact in their work.
Prior to his career as a designer and teacher,
Matt was fellow at the Stanford d. School,
Director of Stanford Sustainable Food Program and
Operations Executive at both Attune and Niman Ranch.
Raised on a 10,000 acre conventional corn farm on the plains of Colorado,
Matt's more formal degrees include a BA in
Environmental Earth Science from Dartmouth College and an
MBA from the Graduate School of Business at Stanford.
And with that, let's turn it over to Matt.
All right. Thank you very much Megan.
And, uh, good morning to everyone out there, it's, uh,
wonderful to see all of your smiling in shining faces this morning.
Um, so I'm looking forward to the conversation today and I think, uh,
maybe to just get us started,
I'll point out, um, a couple of things.
One is the, the title here,
You're Asking The Wrong Questions.
Um, at a high-level, what we're talking about is,
uh, that most people when thinking about problems and solutions often spend, uh,
far more time in thinking about whether or not they have the right, uh,
solution in mind and what we've experienced over a decade of
working with entrepreneurs and innovators in and around the food system is that most,
most people in organizations do not spend
nearly enough time really thinking about the problem that,
that they're trying to solve through the work and through the organization.
And so that's what we're gonna be spending our time on today.
I teach at the Design School here and our goal is always to make,
uh, the teaching and learning that we do as experiential
as possible and I'm gonna attempt to do that today.
And so what I'd like for you to do is if you
have a blank sheet of paper and something with which to write,
uh, in your vicinity,
I'm gonna give you about a minute, uh,
to find that and if you don't have something with which to write,
you don't have a place where you have a piece of paper
available to you but I want you to- to do just to,
uh, think about what I'm asking you here.
So in the next 60 seconds,
what I'd like you to do is to identify
an organizational problem on which you're presently focused.
And I want you to write that down on a piece of paper
or have it in mind, and as you're doing that,
I'd like for you to frame it in a way that I've framed these examples here which
is the problem is that and then fill on the blank to that.
And so I'm giving you range of examples here of things that, uh,
people are often thinking about
problems that they're trying to solve in- in the course of their work.
So I'll give you 60 seconds right now to write the problem that you're
presently focused on in
your organization and then we're gonna come back and we're going to move forward.
Okay. Here we go.
So I'm gonna start by talking a little bit about my background as a way to set up, uh,
how I've gotten here and what you see here is a picture of me and my dad on a combine,
um, on this day, we were combining corn in our 10,000 acre,
uh, farm on the Eastern plains of Colorado.
And I mentioned this because, uh,
as I was approaching graduation from my undergraduate degree,
I recall that my dad,
having thought a lot about what I wanted to do for a career afterwards.
And it occurred to me that farming was really what I wanted to do and so I called
them up and I asked him if I could come back and farm with him an- and I proposed,
uh, because at the time organic was, uh,
kind of taking off in the marketplace I saw it as an opportunity for our farm.
Uh, I proposed to my dad that we begin to convert to,
uh, organic farming, uh,
and that I come back and help him do that.
And, uh, I wasn't prepared for the response he gave me.
Uh, the response was,
uh, sorry son, uh,
we can do neither of those and I think we were both disappointed b-
by that response but what he explained to me
were a couple of problems with our agriculture,
um, which, which I'm showing you here.
The first one is that with respect to organic,
um, from his mind, you know,
the problem is that farmers need to meet the nutritional demands of a growing population
and he just didn't see a way for organic to do that at the time.
And then the second problem that he identified
for me was this problem that with farming is that
the consolidation is making it really hard to pass farms along to the next generation.
And so really for me this
instigated a career in really trying to think about and solve these problems.
And what I'm gonna share with you today is,
is some of my experience and thinking about these problems.
Um, and where we're at, uh,
in terms of working on these today and the work that we're doing now.
More importantly, to think about and share with you
some tools that I've developed along the way that I think will be useful
to you and your organizations as you're thinking about
problems that we're facing today and we've identified just now.
So I think just set this up I wanna share a few kind of key learning moments for me,
uh, along the way in terms of how I got to,
to be doing what I'm doing now.
And the first one it was really, uh,
my initial job out of school working at a ranch
where in the course of the six years I worked there,
we were able to, um,
move from supporting 50 small family farmers to 500.
And for me that became a real example of how we can
scale sustainable agriculture which I then took in to
Business School here with the mindset of really trying to understand better th-
the economics of farming and how we might re-think,
uh, economic relationships between buyers and sellers.
And then unfortunately, in the second year of Business School, uh,
my dad was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer and, um,
which is essentially a year-long death sentence which it turned out to be.
Uh, but in that, in that year, um,
I ended up helping my dad manage my,
our farm and then helping my mom in selling the farm after he passed away.
And there were a couple of really critical moments in that experience as terrible as it
was that really redefined how I think about problems generally,
you know, especially within agriculture and I wanna
share with you is that at this moment that occurred for me.
Um, and so after my dad passed away as we were dealing with,
ah, real estate agent to sell the farm,
he had asked me if I could take a look at my dad's yields as a way to
put a value or help put a value on the farm and so I dug into his files,
and I found, um,
a graph that looks not unlike this one that which
demonstrating the yields of corn over the course of our,
uh, the history of our farm.
And, and what you see here is,
is more or less approximately, um,
what I had seen which was steadily increasing yields over time.
And from the perspective of valuing the farm this was, um,
very helpful because it suggested that the farm is increasing in its value over time.
And so later that afternoon,
so I was looking at this in the morning, later in the afternoon,
we met with the, um,
the real estate agent out on the farm to show him around and give him the tour.
And I'll never forget, uh,
it was such a poignant moment for me that I took a picture of it.
An- and this is the picture that I took.
And so we're sitting on a hill overlooking one of the,
the center pivot irrigation circles on our farm.
And this was I think June or July and it was after, um,
what had been the most rain that we'd received in the spring, um,
in reported history I believe and we are in a short, um,
short grass prairie region which is effectively desert,
we get less than 10 inches of rain a year.
And so it's really unusual to see the kind of green
that we're seeing here and it was really a magnificent sight.
But I was struck by the juxtaposition of that with
the circle that you see there on the left which is brown and ostensibly dead.
And we went down and we took a closer look at it.
And this is a picture o- of that farm,
this is ostensibly where we're growing food.
And I was just struck by the fact that there is, um,
there was nothing growing here and I'm pretty
confident that we had sprayed to kill everything.
But what I noticed was that the soil on this field was just,
um, devoid of life of any kind.
And so in my mind, you know,
as I was looking at this graph earlier in the day realizing what seemed to
be increasing productivity of the farm
and then actually going out and seeing it in this state,
it really occurred to me that something is fundamentally wrong here.
And I didn't maybe think of this problem that my dad, um,
had mentioned as being kind of the fundamental problem of our agriculture was that
farmers need to meet the nutritional demands of a growing population.
And it struck for me just question is,
is this the right problem to be solving to the extent
that we are doing to the soil what we appear to be doing?
And so that launched me on to the path that
I am now really rethinking how we approach agriculture.
I- I want to just
demonstrate the challenge that we face in thinking about problems and one is what,
what I want to demonstrate here.
And that none of us growing up as kids in school
were ever asked the question who knows the right problem.
Th- the question almost always is who
has the right answer and so from our very beginnings,
we are patterned on this idea that there's one problem and one solution.
And this continues into our work culture and our work environments.
And I'm, I'm demonstrating an example here.
This would feel absurd I think to most of us if
anyone asked us the question that's presented here.
And the reality is that we operate in organizations
where we are incentivized to design brilliant solutions.
And we're not incentivized to design brilliant problems.
Now, I think that this quote from Einstein really sums up why this matters.
Uh, and I'll just read it out loud here, uh,
"The formulation of a problem is often more essential than its solution,
which may be merely a matter of mathematical or experimental skill.
To raise new questions,
new problems to rega- regard old problems from a new angle required,
requires creative imagination and marks real advance in science".
And I think that most people generally will believe this
to be true and I certainly have in time that I've been working on this.
Um and what, what Einstein is really talking about here is what, is the,
the language that we use of reframing problems.
But the question, I think,
that most people run into is, yes,
I understand the value of that,
but how do I do that?
And that's what we spent the last 6-7 years, um,
really thinking about and developing tools to help people do this.
I think it's worth mentioning here that our approach to this,
uh, is like I mentioned earlier,
has been through the lens of educators and
practitioners of design, thinking and innovation.
And in, in that practice, um,
our practice is to borrow tools and techniques from
many different disciplines and to think about how we might use them in an applied way,
that are designed to be as useful to,
um, the people using them as possible.
And so our, our lens really is in making tools for people to use,
and in this case, I'm going to show you some of those tools that we've used.
I should also note that, um,
we're not traditional academics and that we don't do research on this stuff.
We often look at research and borrow, um,
what we see as being tools that we can get for,
for people to use like you.
Uh, and I also say that, um,
there is a fair amount of literature out there around,
uh, problem definition, problem solving,
and um, I'm guessing that some of
this will be familiar to those of you who work in those fields,
and if I, um,
haven't cited a reference to your work,
I would love to hear from you.
Uh, I would love to read what you've produced as a way to better,
uh, improve the, the, and inform things that we're doing.
Okay. So the, the one tool that I'll start with, um,
in demonstrating today, is this idea of reframing problems
by identifying causality and constraints around the problem.
And the way that I'm gonna do this is by way of telling a, a, story,
and the story comes from an article that was written in the Harvard Business Review,
I think, uh, five or six years ago.
Uh, it's cited at the end of these slides,
and I'll show this to you, where basically,
the story is of a building manager,
and uh, uh, the building, uh,
we were in a time in like in,
like the mid 1950s,
when um, building tech- elevator technology was advancing rapidly,
and so a lot of people, uh,
in the city were experiencing these,
these elevators that were much faster or becoming much faster,
and as a result of that,
the occupants, the tenants in his building began to
complain about the speed of the elevator in their building.
And so originally, the building manager defined the problem as this one here.
The problem is that people are complaining about the speed of the elevator [NOISE].
And so originally, the building manager was thinking about this and
immediately jumped to thinking about solutions to this problem,
and as with most people,
the first ones that come to mind are obvious solutions to this problem.
And a few that he came to mi- that came to mind for
him were that maybe the elevator needed a faster motor,
maybe there was a new or better algorithm to make the elevator more efficient, um,
and another option, another potential solution was just to,
uh, put in a new elevator altogether.
According the, the, the building manager really started to think about this [NOISE],
and the question he asked himself was,
what might be the, the causes of this problem?
And so what he did is he created
a list on a piece of paper just like the one that you have in front of you,
and the potential causes that he identified for this were,
uh, an obvious one here,
um, the elevator maybe isn't working properly.
Uh, he had noted that new elevators in other buildings were becoming faster,
so maybe that's a part of the problem of people complaining.
And then the third one here, uh,
which I thought was pretty interesting is this id- this,
this potential cause that he identified were maybe it's that
people don't have anything to do while they wait.
And so we're gonna come back to that one,
but in thinking about the causes of the problem,
this is what he had come up with.
So then he got to thinking about, well, okay.
If I'm gonna begin solving these problems,
certainly I'm gonna be working with some constraints.
And so the next thing that he did was he asked himself,
himself, you know, what are
the constraints that I might encounter in solving this problem?
And a couple that he came up with, uh,
were those listed here which is, well,
we don't really have a budget for a new elevator,
so we would need to get new funding to do that.
And in terms of making the elevator,
the existing elevator more efficient, um,
there were not better algorithms on the market,
uh, to help him do that.
[NOISE] Uh, and I think he,
what was really interesting about this example is that he
realized that he could turn all of these causes and all of these,
uh, constraints into problems themselves,
which you can see listed here.
And as he was thinking about this,
he had this sort of 'aha' moment,
and the aha moment was that,
I can choose which of these problems to solve.
And I think this is an important moment and it illustrates the plan made earlier,
which is that for the first time,
he realized that he had agency here to actually define the problem, right?
He started with this original problem that people are
complaining about the speed of the elevator,
but by identifying the actual causes or potential causes of that problem,
thinking through the constraints and trying to solve
the problem and then reframing in these problems,
he had this moment of realizing that there are
more than one problem to be solved here and that he can choose which one to do so.
But then the question was,
which one should I choose?
[NOISE] And as he was thinking about this, um,
he was trying to think through all of the potential questions and things that
he would need to think about in deciding which one to choose,
and he came up with a, with a list of things.
The first one was, um,
for which of these problems do I have the right leverage or influence?
Second one was, for which do I have the right abilities and competencies?
Like, can I do this or not?
Do I have the knowledge or skills?
The third one was, um, for which one do I have the right resources?
Do I have enough money or time to,
to be able to solve this problem?
Another one was, if I try to solve a constraint in particular, uh,
how do I make sure that I'm not just amplifying a cause of the problem to the extent that
it's not focusing in on what is perceived to be the actual cause of,
of this problem [NOISE], of people complaining about the elevator being too slow?
Then the last one was, uh,
and I think this is a really critical one,
what are the potential unintended consequences of solving each of these problems?
[NOISE] And so he went through, uh,
the list of all the problems that he identified
and was thinking through this list of questions that he had,
and so the first one was, yeah.
'The, the problem was if the elevator isn't working properly,' and so um,
he immediately, uh, diagnosed the elevator and it turned out that it was working fine,
so that was not the problem.
He took a look at 'the problem is the elevator, uh,
or that new elevators in other buildings are becoming much faster,'
but he realized that he didn't really have any leverage or influence in changing that,
and so that wasn't, apparently,
a very good problem for him to tackle.
He took a look at 'the problem is that people don't have anything to do
while they wait,' and on this one, he,
he thought to himself, "Well, I may or may not ha- have the right abilities or resources,
but I'm not sure."
He then took a look at 'the, the constraints as he had turned them into problems,
and the problem is that we don't have a budget for a new
elevator,' and as he thought about this,
the question that came to mind was, well,
if we raise rents to buy a new elevator,
we might actually draw more attention to the elevator itself,
and so it seemed to him that there might be
an unattended consequence here of actually trying to fix the elevator.
And in the last one, um,
'the problem is that the better algorithms don't yet exist.'
He thought to himself, "Well, I don't have the right abilities, uh, to do,
to design a better algorithm,
but if I did, I might just be creating this sort of,
this idea of a reinforcing feedback loop of having to always have the fastest
elevator," and so he would kinda get stuck in
this trap of having to always be solving this problem.
And so as he stepped back and he took a look at all these problems that he identified,
potential problems that he could begin, um,
or that he could start with trying to solve,
the one that he identified was this one,
which is the problem, is that people don't have anything to do while they wait.
And so um, he,
as he was thinking about [NOISE] trying to solve this problem,
he did some research and,
um, what he discovered was that there's actually a lot of work done around,
um, what's known as queuing theory [NOISE].
And if you ever go to Disneyland or a large amusement park,
they spend a lot of time thinking about how
to entertain people while they're waiting for rides.
Um, and what he discovered in that research was that,
if you install mirrors around the elevator,
as you can see here,
people will be happy to wait if they have time to look at themselves,
to prep themselves, and to look at how beautiful they are.
And so I think that this is
a really beautiful example of how reframing problems in this way,
really thinking about, what are the real causes of the problem that I'm starting with?
What are the constraints around trying to solve that problem?
Thinking through those questions,
around which ones are,
um, do I have the abilities and competencies,
the resources to solve,
can lead to really easy elegant solutions.
And the point of all this,
the underlying reason why this works in terms of innovation is this;
reframing problems helps us get away from the obvious solutions, right?
So had he, uh, only focused on
the original problem of people complaining about the speed of the elevator,
he would have likely invested in a new motor,
maybe a new control algorithm,
or maybe he would have purchased a new elevator altogether.
But by reframing that original problem,
what he was able to do was to define a new problem,
and that led to less obvious solutions,
uh, which for him were mirrors around doors.
And what you see here is,
is a representa- representation of
the potential solution set that's related to how we define a problem,
and in this case,
by re- reframing the problem,
he was able to open up the number of potential solutions, and when you do that,
it becomes just a, a, a math, uh,
equation and that you have
many more potential solutions to draw from in solving the problem.
This is really critical to how we think about, um,
leading to or binding creative solutions,
innovative solutions to existing problems.
[NOISE] And so what I want you to do now is to
take a look at the problem that you've identified or to come back to it in,
in your head if you, if you think,
if you thought about it originally [NOISE],
and as you're thinking about this problem,
what I want you to realize is that this problem and
every problem is caused by something else [NOISE].
This problem and every problem is constrained by something,
and importantly, these causes and constraints can be reframed as other problems.
And as, as you're thinking about your problem,
I would encourage you,
either now or afterwards,
to think about how you might do this [NOISE].
I think it's really important to remember that
re-framing problems often leads to unexpected and innovative solutions.
I think that the mirrors around the elevator are a great example of this.
But in the work that we've done,
we've seen hundreds of examples of this happening.
In fact, we see it everyday in the classes that we teach here.
And I think it's important as you're doing this to be aware
of unintended consequences when solving for constraints.
Um, I'm going to talk a little bit about this later on but often,
when we try to solve for constraints,
we're either solving for time and money or for new technologies.
And the challenge of solving for time and money is that, um,
from our experience it often really limits the potential solution
set and so it doesn't allow you to get to really creative innovative solutions.
And a challenge with using new technology to solve constraints, which in,
in my experience of working with a lot of
organizations is often the direction that they head,
is that it's really difficult when solving for a constraint to, um,
be unaware or not think about
the potential unintended consequences that might result from that technology.
We see this all the time where new technologies simply
amplify the underlying cause of the problem that we're trying to solve.
And I'm going use an example later to make that point.
And then the last thing,
as you're thinking about, um,
this problem that you have, is the,
the second aspect of,
of what I want to share with you today.
And it's this idea of always being mindful of
human needs as we're thinking about re-framing and defining problems.
And I'm going to spend a little time, um,
talking about that now and I think that this is probably the best image
that I have found to describe what I see hundreds of times with organizations.
And this is true of
entrepreneurial startups to established industry players
that have been around for a long time.
And the, the reality that I see is that most organizations tend to
focus on the needs of the organizations and not
squarely or specifically on the needs of their customers,
clients, their service recipients,
um, their students in some cases.
And so the goal of defining problems is to make
sure or to be aware of the fact that this exists pretty frequently,
and to align these two things in ways that solve both needs.
And so I want to run through an example of,
uh, what this looks like and how to do this.
So, um, I have a question for you and as you're looking at this picture,
the question is what does this girl need?
And I want you to just think about that for a couple seconds.
[NOISE] That if you're
like most of the students in our classes and most of the executives,
uh, at the business school where I teach,
the first couple of things that come to mind is that she needs
a book or that she needs a ladder.
And the question that I- that I want to ask of you is,
why does she need a book and why does she need a ladder?
And most often the answer to why does she need a book is she needs a way to learn.
I think this is important, this is what we referred to as a needs ladder and well,
in design as we think about needs,
our goal is to identify both the explicit and implicit needs that people have.
And so in this case, the explicit need would be,
uh, a book or a ladder.
Whereas the implicit need would be that she needs a way to learn.
And this is really important um, again,
in terms of defining problems to
maximize the potential for innovative and creative solutions,
and I want to show you again why that is.
So in this example,
the obvious or explicit need that
most people identify in that example is that she needs a ladder or a book.
But if we open up the question, uh,
to her need as being a way to learn,
what that does is it opens up the total potential solution set, right?
There are many potential solutions to a way to learn for her.
Whereas a ladder or a book are very specific solutions.
And again, this is an example of how by identifying these implicit needs,
we're able to just open up the potential solution set.
And what that does is it offers an opportunity to identify
truly innovative and new creative ways of solving problems for people.
Now, there's another aspect of this is important to keep in mind and
this is a picture of Maslow's Hierarchy,
uh, with which some of you are probably familiar.
Um, I think those of you who are familiar with it know that in psychology
this has become a defunct way of thinking about psychology and people.
But for our purposes is actually really useful,
and the reason that it's useful is that it is a pretty fair representation of,
um, moving from explicit needs,
which in this case, are more like physiological needs around food, breathing, water.
Towards moving up to more implicit needs that people have around social,
psychological, and emotional needs.
And the value of this is that what we know
from a lot of experience and from a lot of demonstration,
is that if you're able to frame a problem that
incorporates an implicit, a social, emotional,
or psychological need of a person or of people and to design a solution for that need,
you're far more likely to design something that that person will actually want to use.
And as we think about, um,
innovation, getting new people to try new things,
this a really critical aspect of driving innovation in, through problem definition.
Okay. So I want to come back to the example of the building manager and
the problems that he identified having
moved through identifying the causes and the constraints and turning those into problems.
Um, what- what you'll note here is that the one that he chose focused on people.
Now, this is coincidental to a certain extent,
but I think it's a great way of
illustrating the example or the point that I'm making here.
And so what I want you to do now is to take a look at the problem that you've identified.
And what I'd like you to do is to ask yourself,
if you haven't already involved people in some way in,
in the definition of the problem,
is how could you re-frame this problem to involve people in some way?
How could you identify an explicit need here?
Which is to say, what do these people need to be able to
do as part of the definition of your problem?
And then the last one and this is really critical,
is as you're thinking about defining or re-framing this problem,
how can you re-frame the problem in a way that identifies a need,
uh, for the people in this problem to feel?
And I think that in my experience of working with students and executives,
that this is probably the most critical aspect of thinking about how to define problems.
Um, if we can't or aren't able to identify
and solve for needs that people have in this regard,
it's very unlikely that the solutions we're going to develop will be adopted or,
um, desired by the people for whom we're designing [NOISE].
[NOISE] But I- I wanted to leave with kind of the story of the work that we've
been doing as a way to illustrate I think what I
have come to see as the most important thing around problem definition.
And so I mentioned earlier this tension between, um,
this problem that our agriculture is trying to solve,
which is the problem is that farmers need to meet
the nutritional demands of a growing population.
Yet, at the same time, uh,
we're seeing, uh, that our farmland end up looking like this.
We're effectively destroying the soil.
And I want to tell a story,
a personal story to help illustrate,
I think, what is at the fundamental challenge of this now that-
that I think exists within many industries and sectors.
So this is a picture of me and my grandpa when I was young.
And my grandpa was, uh,
fond of telling this story,
although I never- I never heard it.
My dad actually told it to me when- when,
um, when he was sick.
And the story is how the tractor ruined farming.
And the story is- basically, it goes like this.
Originally, the- the primary technology on our farms were horses,
and- and that was fine.
Um, we get up in the morning,
we feed the horses, we feed ourselves,
we saddle them up, we take them out,
we'd work until noon,
we'd come back, we'd eat, uh,
and then we'd go back and we work in the afternoon until either we
couldn't work anymore or the horses couldn't work anymore.
And then one day, um,
the tractor was invented.
And th- the promise of the tractor was amazing.
It was gonna make a lot of money for farmers,
it was gonna save us a lot of time,
um, we were gonna be happier.
And so we bought a tractor, and everything was great.
Uh, the tractor was definitely more efficient.
But we didn't realize a couple of things in buying the tractor.
And one was that this tractor required maintenance,
uh, it required fuel.
And as farmers, we didn't have a ton of money on the balance sheet.
And so we had to borrow money,
we had to take out an operating loan to- to- just to run the tractor.
And that was on top of the loan we had to sneak out to buy
the tractor. And so that was fine.
But what we realized was that,
this tractor was actually so productive that we
didn't have enough farmland to actually make it pay for itself.
And so what we had to do was we had to buy more land just to make the tractor,
um, pay for itself.
And so as a result of that,
we took out another mortgage,
we bought more land,
and we started farm- farming efficiently,
and finally, we were able to pay off the tractor.
And for a short period of time, this was great.
We were making a little bit more money,
we were definitely more efficient.
But what happened was that everybody started buying tractors.
And everybody was buying more land,
and everybody was producing more food.
And in the short period of time,
as a result of that,
was, uh, more food on the market.
The price of that food began to decline.
For consumers, this was great.
But for farmers, this wasn't so great.
What it meant was that from moving from the horses to tractors,
we had taken on a bunch of debt.
And at the end of the day, because a falling through prices,
we weren't any better off economically.
And as my dad was telling me this story,
I realized that this was an allegory for
pretty much every technology that has been developed in our agriculture since.
And it's all been in service of this question of how are we
going to feed all of these people in this growing population?
And so when I saw our farm looking like this,
that was the moment when I realized I think that we're solving the wrong problem here.
And when you think about what is the real problem that we're trying to solve,
I was notified of this- this fact a couple of years ago,
and it really struck me.
And I've reframed it here.
The problem is that the United Nations Food and Agri Organization estimates that
we have 60 global harvests remaining before we're unable to feed everyone.
And this is largely a result of the way that we farm,
and by literally destroying the soil on which we rely to grow food.
It's clear to me, through my experience that
the problem we're trying to solve is the wrong problem.
And I think what I've learned is that the solution to this,
and generally speaking, this is true of this problem,
and it's true of the problem you have in front of you.
Is that the solution is to solve the causes of these problems,
and to solve the implicit needs of people.
And I'm confident based on all of our experience in the work that we're doing,
and through many examples of, uh,
thought leaders and others in the food system who are doing this.
That if we begin to think this way and frame our pro- problems in this way,
then we truly have an opportunity to solve some
of these deeply systemic issues that we face,
and whatever the sectors and industries are that we operate.
And I'm hoping that by way of today,
that this gives you some tools for you to do this within your organizations,
and it gives you some power to reframe these problems in ways
that will result in positive outcomes for people and our planet.
And I think that that's all that I've got for today. Thank you.
Great. Thank you very much,
Matt for this very informative presentation.
And I hope that all of you have spent some time,
rethinking the organizational challenge you wrote
down in the very beginning of Matt's framework and ideas.
Okay. So I am seeing that we have,
uh, few questions along the same theme.
So I will make sure to,
uh, propose that one first.
So people are asking about, um,
you know, finding, you know,
talking about finding the problem, identifying the problem,
um, and so to sum up several of these different types of questions,
people would first like to know,
um, what kind of preparation or legwork should
they be doing before they feel like they're ready to identify the real problem?
Is there any- anything that they should- should do?
Yeah. No. I- I think, um, you know, uh,
as we've thought about these tools, um,
I think the real value of them is that they can be applied today,
to whatever the problem is that you're working on.
And this could be- we've done this with teams and with executives,
um, who- who encounter problems on a daily basis, uh, recurring problems.
It could be in the strategic setting.
So it is really designed as a way to, uh,
think about whatever the problem is that's in front of you.
Whether it's something that's happening that you didn't expect,
or whether there's something that you're thinking about long-term or strategically.
Um, and so- so really,
the preparation is just wherever you're at, begin there.
Great. And, uh, would you say- so this is the other side of the question that's gotten.
Um, would you say that's the same if you're trying to,
um, find kind of the cause of the consumer problem?
So if you look at it the other way,
not internal, but the external, identifying their problems.
Yeah. For sure.
Um, and I think- so there- I guess there are a couple of things,
uh, ar- around that.
One is, um, we- and this gets into,
uh, another aspect of- of design thinking today- I haven't touched on today.
Um, the design thinking is also known as human-centered design.
Um, and what that really means is that,
if you're thinking about, um,
how to design something, whether it's a product,
or a service, or experience for a consumer, or a customer,
or client, or somebody external to the organization, um,
we- we often believe that we both know what their problem is,
and what the solution is to that.
And as a fundamental assumption that needs to be challenged.
Mm-hmm.
And the way to challenge that assumption is by actually
talking to your customers, your clients,
and your- and your customers to identify what are
the real both explicit and implicit needs that they have,
and then determine that learning into what you think that the problem is.
Now, I will say, and I think it's really critical,
in- in every aspect of thinking about problems,
is that, um, when we define a problem,
I think the best way to think about it is as a hypothesis and not as-
Mm-hmm.
-um, the, you know,
set in stone statement of what we think the problem is.
You know, we are inferring what we think the problem is.
And in design what we teach is to think about that problem as a hypothesis to
develop some ideas or concepts that we think
might solve the need or problem that we've identified.
And to test that a bunch of times is a way to both refine
the framing of the problem based on what we're learning
through th- through the testing and the experimentation,
as well as to understand is- is this idea solving the need that we've identified or not.
And I think that there's a lot of value to doing that.
Um, first of all, it ensures that the problem that you're
focusing on is a real problem to be solved,
that people have these real needs.
And it also saves a lot of time and money, um,
before investing a lot of money
into what we think of as being the solution to your problem,
only to realize once it's been out in the market that nobody actually wants it.
And, um, we refer to this, uh,
pretty frequently as technologies in sear- in- in- in,
um, search of a need.
And we see this all the time here in Silicon Valley,
um, that I- I've been a part of a startup for which that was the case as well.
So, uh, several people are also asking, um,
so once a problem has been identified and properly framed,
is there a certain thought process in identifying the steps towards the solution?
Yeah. Um, so once you have a problem in mind,
again, I think the most important thing is to think about it as a hypothesis.
And, um, in terms of moving towards solutions,
uh, what we recommend is, uh, and what we practice,
and this is- this is a core to design thinking, um,
is to develop a number of potential solutions to that problem.
Right? And so, you know,
the- the relationship between problem definition,
as I mentioned earlier, and a potential solution set is really important.
So you've got the right framing,
it's going to open up the potential solutions.
And what that really means is that there are a lot of potential solutions in that.
The goal is to identify as many of those as possible,
and then degrade a way to think about which of them,
um, is likely to solve the- the need or a problem that we have.
Which do we have the resources available to pursue?
Which of them are really creative and innovative?
Which of them, um,
might or might not create unintended consequence,
if we're thinking about,
uh, bringing them to life? Um.
Then, to before, again,
before taking those ideas from that,
from that potential set,
to do some very early testing of those ideas,
and we literally do notes on pieces of paper in front
of the people for whom we're solving just to get a sense of,
is this idea great or not?
Is this really the need that you've
identified with the problem that we're trying to solve?
And then doing that, many times,
in an innovative way to get to a place where we feel like that idea or
solution concept is really leading
the meter in solving the problem that we've identified.
Great. Um, so people are also asking a lot of questions about,
um, hidden and implicit needs and identifying those.
Yeah.
So, um, do you have any techniques for really discovering these?
Especially, if it's a society that perhaps has poor communication, um,
or you don't have the same type of accesses,
you know, some of the companies in Silicon Valley may have to, to people at serving.
Yeah. Um, so, what- what I'll say is that,
generally speaking, um, there are a lot.
In a corporate context, there are a lot,
there are many constraints around using the techniques that we use in design to uncover,
uh, the implicit needs that people have.
Um, that- that would be hours of conversation to explain those,
but in our context the goal of ide- how to identify the implicit needs that people have,
is really under, trying to understand what they care about and what motivates them.
The simplest way to put that is to
understand why people say what they say in response to your,
to the questions that you might ask.
There is an expression of five whys to cry and medics put
that expression as rooted in this idea that if you ask somebody why to the same question,
same question and answer, um,
you will eventually get to this thing that they most deeply care about.
The goal in having conversations with
our customers or clients or service recipients and our students,
is really to understand at that level like,
what do they really care about,
and that helps to provide insight into
the context of whatever the problem is that you're trying to solve.
Whether it's as a product or a service or some kind of an experience.
Great. So, I think we have time for maybe one or two more.
So, people are asking about root cause analysis.
Yeah.
Um, specifically, if it differs from
problem identification or are they essentially the same.
You know, so, um,
I'll, I'll answer that in two ways.
One is that, um,
as I mentioned, I'm not an academic.
So, um, if we pull the end and we also pull from a lot of different disciplines,
um, I'm familiar with root cause analysis but I'm not an expert in it.
But as I know it it's effectively into
my mind essentially the same thing of really understanding,
identifying what is the root cause of the problem that we're working on.
I know that there are a lot of tools and techniques and
processes that people use in that discipline to do that,
um, and I think that that's a great source of,
of information and thinking about,
you know, working with this,
this problem that I have and using those tools from that discipline
to identify what those root causes might be. For sure.
Um, so, the last one that I think we'll have time for.
So, um, a lot of people are, I think,
trying to figure out how to re-frame their own,
um, their own questions and challenges.
Yeah.
So, um, perhaps we could answer most of these types of questions,
um, if you could talk about how you re-framed the,
you know, this issue of meeting nutritional needs of a growing population.
Like, how- how did you re-frame that?
Yeah. That's a great question.
So, I think in, in a couple of ways.
Um, one is that,
uh, I see the problem, so,
we- I've re-framed that problem as, um,
the problem is that we need to maximize the productive capacity of our soils.
Um, and that takes into account what we are actually doing to our soils,
which is diminishing their viability over long-term.
It's also inclusive of this problem that we need to
maximize productivity in order to produce food for this growing population.
So I re-framed it in that way,
to be inclusive of both of those problems.
There's a separate problem, um,
that we've re-framed in a way on to identify people in their implicit needs, and the,
the question that we, that I often ask
of entrepreneurs and people who are working in foods specifically,
um, or in agriculture is,
um, how can we grow,
produce, sell, and consume food that unlocks the potential of humans.
I like that one because it really re-frames food as being just calories that feed
people to food as being a tool to really unlock and tap into the potential of people.
I think by thinking about it that way,
it just really re-frames, like,
how we think about the utility of food in a very different way.
I think it begins to get at or encompass some of the really,
um, terrible problems that were, that were existing,
that exists in the system today with respect to food and people around,
um, the skyrocketing obesity rates that we're seeing,
the rates of type two diabetes that exists today, um,
the inequities in the system that leads to a billion people on the planet,
um, either starving or being malnourished.
Um, and so, I think that,
I think that if we can solve that problem, uh,
we will be going,
to focus on that as being the problem.
I think that we'll go a long way in designing a food system that
actually has people at its center and that is trying to make health be productive,
um, and to help them realize their potential negotiate possible.
Great. So, thank you so much and thank you everyone for submitting,
uh, submitting your questions.
Um, unfortunately we're getting close to the hour,
so we'll have to wrap the Q and A.
Thank you so much Matt for sharing your knowledge and thank you for,
uh, to our participants for today.
Those of you who have indicated an interest in the program,
our team will be reaching out with more information and you
can always visit us at globalimpact.stanford.edu.
Thanks all for joining us today and have a great rest of your week.